for the last nine months Santiago
Sanchez has been documenting his journey
on foot to this year's World Cup after
hiking through 15 countries and sharing
his adventures on social media he sent
his last audio message to his parents at
the start of October as he headed for
Iran
tomorrow I'm going to Tehran to the
capital the TV is going to film a report
on me and from there we're going to
Banda Abbas once there close to the port
we'll catch a ship to Qatar
I'll make videos or whatever that's the
reality okay
Sanchez's parents say there's been no
communication with him since then
he's not politically involved he does
not belong to any political party he's
not been making propaganda neither for
nor against any situation the only thing
that moves him is supporting Real Madrid
and walking to get to the World Cup in
Qatar
Sanchez had recently walked through the
Kurdish region of Iraq a local farmer
there hosted the Spaniard before he
continued his journey
he said I'm going to Iran I'm going to
BestMark border gate where is the road
to Benchmark we said this road takes you
to Benchmark and so he took his bike we
were busy working in the farm planting
apples and picking tomatoes but at 8 30
in the morning he headed for the road
after he had had some bread and tea
back in his hometown Sanchez's parents
have been speaking out
he said to me Mom I'm going to tell you
something you can keep in your head
forever I'd rather die than live quietly
I was born to help others to help nature
and if I die don't cry I would have died
happy because I would have done what I
wanted mum
Spain's foreign Ministry says their
Ambassador in Tehran is working to
locate Sanchez David Stokes Al Jazeera